I'm a huge Sons fan and I have to ask
you because you and this guy aren't
necessarily tied together but you guys
do have some
kind of uh coincidental yeah we gotta
it's like yeah you and Chris Paul for
sure because obviously you leave the
Clippers yeah for sure you leave the
Hornets Chris Paul comes in with a
better team
um what's your relationship like with CP
I have friends on the Suns and I would
say most of my friends are not too fond
of Chris what is your like does he get a
bad rap amongst other NBA players and
how's your guys's relationship because
you guys are kind of tied together with
two franchises yeah yeah and crazy
enough uh I got all the love and respect
for Chris Paul
when Chris Paul was at Wake Forest I
called Chris Paul when I was in the
league like yo bro I [__] with you I
think his grandfather died
and I was like man shouting you out like
you gonna you know what I mean just like
kind of like you know we have
Brotherhood at the end of the day for
sure so like me and Chris have always
been linked like that and so when I left
Charlotte New Orleans and he came in I I
kind of figured like all right I'm gonna
clean this [__] up and then I'm gonna
let Chris Paul me and Chris Paul gonna
come in and take it you know to another
level but you know I just think as a
player like he's an incredible point
guard yeah you know what I mean I think
that he's a legend yeah he's a rising
guy it feels like with like his
teammates yeah he's a big personality I
think when you look at him you think you
know CEO president you know what I mean
corporate he did President NBA Players
Association of the NBA players so when
you looking at that you know at your
leader out there on the floor you know
like he he coming with the full
corporate you know what I mean corporate
like he running it he running that team
the way he want to run a team you feel
very much a coach on the floor Bingo
yeah he'll be a great he'll be a man
excellent coach for sure he will be an
excellent coach yeah he's like uh like
you said like he's he's very much
he's running the team away yeah he's
just he worked yeah he come in like his
[__] is corporate business you've played
for a lot of coaches and I do feel like
that we'll see certain teams like make a
coaching change and it's like day and
night right how important is
coach like a coach like on an NBA team
because a lot of times you'll hear I
guess
generic basketball fans it's about it's
in the players hands like the players
ain't performing man nah it's like you
played for some bad coaches you played
for some great coaches it was some
terrible coaches I played for some great
coaches too I played for some coaches at
had we had one or two other pieces they
would have been Hall of Fame you know
what I mean championship coaches
um
the team Dynamic and the coach Dynamic
like you need a good coach good coaches
are hard to come by what determines a
good coach you know what I mean a lot of
coaches when they come into the business
they like they have established who they
are their style what they're gonna do
a lot of times
coaches that are players must separate
themselves from the players today in
order to be okay coaching them I was
gonna say you know what I mean it seems
like at times like if there's a guy who
used to play they kind of yeah hey dude
Mike Dunleavy he played in the league
and all he would talk about
in reference is when he played which was
like in the [__] 70s gives a [__]
right
you're not like and you're a point guard
so like I used to always be like like
yeah when I play I said coach if you
played in this area bro I swear to God I
elbow you in your face I follow you to
the locker room elbow you again well he
wasn't a great coach he was not that
great of a coach Mike doesn't leave me
but he was tough he wasn't to get along
he he was his son ever on your guys's
team no I played with Mike Mike Jr Mike
Jr is dope he was cool I played with
Mike Jr in Golden State
um he actually got he was the trade he
was the person that they traded to
Indiana for stack uh and Al Harrington
but like such a crazy team it was it was
a how much weed was getting passed
around in that in those off off season
when you guys were like you know how
many moves together all the time
everybody was up yeah one of the highest
teams in the NBA it was up it was up you
had Al Harrington Stephen
well he's got a week
yeah yeah but he he face that off his
grandma and then Matt Barnes Matt Barnes
pothead oh my goodness Stephen Jackson
pothead
me I'm smoking
I'm a smoker I'm not a pothead just I
mean I wouldn't say that I'm a I'm a a
smoke right but I ain't no pot you know
I guess now maybe [__]